there are ways to help keep some of the  costs down southwest gas recommends  setting your daytime thermostat between  65 to 68 degrees and maybe lowering it  at nighttime change and clean your air  filters on a regular base that also  helps and and finally seal any cracks or  leaks around doors or windows that can  help keep some of that warm air inside  especially right now because it's so  cold outside you definitely want to do  everything to kind of keep yourself warm  yeah 65 that's two that's too chilly for  me  right am i right yes guilty yeah that's  probably what my bill is like huge  i need warm  70. i need 70s i keep it cool do you  really oh yeah where do you keep yours  at i'm more or less about like 66 i like  it nice and cool do you have icicles in  your house  i'm just kidding i have a lot of  blankets